by satellite from London England where
Big Ben has just got 3 a.m. too
from Moscow Russia where Russian film
stars have gathered just two blocks from
Red Square from Sydney Australia where
it is already 12 noon tomorrow
from Tokyo Japan and a motion picture
sound state with some very special
people
from Buenos Aires Argentina where the
Argentinian film community is gathered
at the famous TF book alone and from Los
Angeles California at the Dorothy
Chandler Pavilion
it's the 62nd annual Academy Awards
brought to you by Revlon the most
unforgettable women in the world where
Revlon JCPenney
you're looking smart never at jcpenney
today's chevrolet who invites you to see
why nobody's winning like the heartbeat
of America as the coca-cola company and
your local coca-cola bottler
some of the early arrivals last year's
Best Actress winner Jodie Foster
here's Best Actor about me for my
also nominated for best
William Freeman
presenting one of the major awards
mr. Dudley Moore
on the 4th of July Ron Kovic
beautiful Isabelle Adjani nominated for
Best Actress
very funny Chevy Chase
Best Supporting Actor Martin Landau this
necklace on me Jessica Tandy and her
husband he voted Oscar winner Jessica
Lange not named again Lee she ate
Tom Hanks nominated last year for best
actors director of box-office
blockbuster Steven Spielberg
Supporting Actress nominee Julia Roberts
those beautiful fresh flowers are all
from Holland
here's best song on the Randy Newman
this actor nominee for the second time
from the accounting firm of Price
Waterhouse
guarantee the secrecy and the integrity
of the results mr. Frank Johnson and mr.
dan wile and he is best supporting
actress Brenda Fricker
but fabulous Diana Ross and her
daughters
arnold schwarzenegger and his wife maria
shriver and
the truck
a great palate a favorite Steve Martin
incredible Darrell hello
here's Don Johnson and his wife Libby
Griffith nominated last year the best
actress
not made it for the second year
you
the ever-popular Tom Selleck
Oscar nominee Michelle Pfeiffer and the
Fabulous Baker boys both and Jeff
Bridges Oscar winner Geena Davis with
husband Jeff Oscar nominee and Oscar
winner director Oliver Stone
oscar-winner anomaly and again this year
Angelica Houston Miss Kim Basinger
here singer James Ingram
and oscar-winning star mr. Walter
Matthau
ladies and gentlemen Academy Award
winner and president of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences mr.
Karl Malden
and here tonight I'm here tonight to
tell you that Oscar's beside himself I
mean this is one of those nights when
one world is more than a philosophical
dream it's a reality and I'm thrilled to
be the one to get to throw out the first
hello to all of you here in Dorothy
Chandler Pavilion and all of you out
there joining our party by satellite
north-south-east-west
wherever there's a love of going to the
movies and a passionate interest in the
people who make them and to me that
means just about everyone everywhere and
that's why we're gathered here tonight
to celebrate excellence in the art of
filmmaking
and as I look at you men and women who
were nominated for Academy Awards I
think of your individual accomplishments
this past year and I congratulate you
from the bottom of my heart my envious
heart
if I were lucky enough to win one of
those golden Oscars again I tell you I
would never leave home without it so
here we are poised on the edge of the
final decade of the 20th century dazzled
by the swift changes that are taking
place all over the world and films have
leaked across national boundaries
overcome disparate languages brushed
aside political differences and brought
people closer together by depicting our
common shared humanity anyone who has
ever been a part of the filmmaking
process has a right to feel proud of
that and it's only the beginning for the
movies there are miracles of technology
we haven't even dreamt up yet for
instance films distributed around the
planet by satellite directly to every
home on earth by the world I mean how
can you have a closed society when the
skies are open from Moscow to Beijing -
well you name Gary in the end I tell you
what a world but anyway listen it's time
to celebrate and party tonight so I want
to thank you all for coming and wherever
you are have a great time and for you
nominees I dare you to be relaxed
tonight